sa parole est maintenant aux orateurs
des groupes notre collègue robert
navarro non-inscrits pour 3 minutes la
parole monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
oui la grèce reste dans la zone euro et
cela reste une bonne nouvelle même si
des rebondissements ne sont pas à
exclure mais les dirigeants européens
ont imposé un véritable traité de
versailles au peuple grec
une punition une humiliation d'une
violence inouïe
je suis un ardent défenseur de l'europe
depuis le début de mon engagement
politique
mais force est de constater que l'union
européenne a changé de nature ce
week-end
d'abord j'ai appris que l'euro n'était
pas que le mollet mais aussi une
politique économique particulière l'euro
devait rapprocher les peuples être la
monnaie de tous les européens
or cette crise a prouvé que nos on peut
priver certains habitants de réseaux
neuraux de l'accès à l'eau propre
monnaie jusqu'à ce week-end l'europe
c'était la convergence progressive de
natio égal en une union sans cesse plus
étroit chaque état membre choisissez
librement de confier à l'union une part
de sa souveraineté dans son propre
intérêt
chaque pas vers l'europe était
irréversible et irrévocable en fait
l'accord tacite et et que l'allemagne
devait se retenir de toute tentation
impérialiste en échange de la seconde
chance donnée depuis lundi matin cela
met plus la grèce n'est plus morel
l'irréversibilité de l'euro est morte
tous les irréversible du projet européen
sont devenus réversible tous les
irrévocable sont devenus révocable la
zone euro n'est plus un projet politique
commun qui supposerait la prise en
compte des aspirations de tous par des
compromis équilibré ce week-end est
devenu un lieu de domination des forces
les faibles des créanciers ce que les
débiteurs la cruauté de ce week-end est
un avertissement pour les pays latins
dont la france droite comme à gauche
devrait chercher la parade pour que de
se renvoyer la balle
car ils n'ont jamais mené le politique
économique qui convienne à l'allemagne
tôt ou tard
au rythme où va notre dette nous
connaîtront le même sort si nous ne
devrions rien ne tombe pas vraiment
vinci sur le vraiment l'union européenne
d'ailleurs il ne s'agit plus de
réorienter mais de refonder ce week-end
les dirigeants européens ont ouvert une
boîte de pandore qui pourrait coûter
cher à l'europe et au fond de boulevard
aux extrêmes
c'est de cela dans les politiques
devrait s'occuper pas de débat entre
sarkozystes et hollandais pour savoir
qui a sauvé l'intégrité de la zone euro
car en réalité ils sont responsables
tous de la tournure prise par l'union
européenne depuis la crise de 2008 une
crise de spéculateurs né aux états unis
il faut ça rappelait en a trop tendance
à l'oublier
à l'heure de l'addition merci mon cher
collègue
la parole est maintenant président
françois zocchetto pour le groupe union
centriste pour 8 minutes
la parole monsieur le président monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre des
affaires étrangères mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues le premier ministre avait
annoncé vouloir revenir devant le
parlement pour soumettre aux
représentants du peuple l'approbation
d'un éventuel accord
dont acte disons le d'emblée notre
groupe se félicite de la conclusion de
cet accord j'ai bien dit de cet accord
bien précis et pas de n'importe quel
accord nous ne pouvions évidemment pas
abandonner les grecs à leur sort ni pour
eux mêmes ni pour l'europe ne pouvions
pas nous satisfaire d'ingres excite de
lassitude
nous ne pouvions pas non plus lassés des
dizaines de milliards d'euros d'argent
public par dessus l'épaule du
contribuable sans perspective de
redressement durable pour la grèce
en l'état cet accord a le mérite de
garder la grèce dans la zone euro sans
discréditer l'union mais que de temps
perdu entre la révélation en décembre
2009 du trucage des comptes publics
grecs et la conclusion de ce troisième
plan
de financière la grèce a perdu 6 années
six années de réformes inabouties six
années de souffrance pour les grecs
et tout cela pour quoi pour aboutir
enfin à une conclusion déjà écrites
depuis longtemps à savoir la grèce pour
rester dans la zone euro doit se mettre
en conformité avec les exigences
imposées par la monnaie unique
ça n'a rien d'extraordinaire l'europe
exige un devoir de solidarité en dehors
entre tous ses membres bien sûr mais
cette solidarité impose en retour un
devoir de responsabilité pour chacun
j'espère que monsieur qui brasse et ses
amis ou enfin compris la portée de ce
principe
cet accord met le gouvernement devant le
gouvernement grec devant ses obligations
j'ai déjà évoqué ici à cette tribune il
ya une semaine les réformes à
entreprendre
nous les connaissons tous restauration
de l'autorité de l'état grec
la réforme fiscale lutte contre la
corruption lutte contre la fraude
démantèlement des oligopoles
instauration d'un cadastre et soumission
de tous à l'impôt que l'on soit amateur
ou l'église orthodoxe y compris pour que
la confiance soit rétabli entre la grèce
et ses partenaires il faudra que
monsieur de sipera ce aille au bout des
réformes promises
évidemment cela ne sera pas facile
appliquer l'accord à la lettre demandera
des efforts considérables aux grecs et
je ne change pas seulement à des efforts
financiers mais un véritable et profond
changement d'attitude des citoyens grecs
un changement des mentalités s'impose
pour construire un état fort pour
respecter cet état grec on mettre au pas
les profiteurs d'une société vicié par
les rentes et par le népotisme la grèce
ne peut plus jouer au passager
clandestin de la construction européenne
c'est un moment de vérité pour la grèce
qui en pleine souveraineté est désormais
face à son destin
c'est donc à son peuple dans sont
montrés dignes d'affronter cette épreuve
en toute responsabilité
sans dénoncer ce qu'ils l'aident depuis
tant d'années l'allemagne en premier
chef
et là monsieur le ministre permettez moi
de vous dire avec tristesse au lendemain
du 14 juillet que je me suis senti plus
en phase avec la proche allemande de la
solidarité qu'avec celle de notre
gouvernement
les allemands conservateurs et sociaux
démocrates voulaient un bon accord
le président la république française de
son côté déclaré vouloir un accord à
tout prix
quelles différences et bien du côté
français on pouvait comprendre que nous
étions prêts à lâcher à nouveau
l'argent public pour éteindre un
incendie qui aurait probablement repris
très vite
côté allemand et d'autres pays nombreux
il s'agissait d'abord de jeter les bases
d'une croissance saine en grèce à
laquelle nous aurons je l'espère envie
toute façon nous aurons l'obligation
j'en suis certain d'associer un
nécessaire rayonnement voir remise de la
dette grecque
alors on parle beaucoup de la grèce mais
on peut aussi parler un peu de la france
nous devons aussi regarder la réalité je
ne citerai pas beaucoup de chiffres mais
en france la dette par habitant est de
31 mille euros en grèce elle est de 29
mille la réalité
la vérité c'est quoi c'est qu'un pays
n'est pas souverain quand il est
surendetté et la grèce nous le
démontrons
je ne peux donc que m'inquiéter de ce
soulagement qui semble gagner le
gouvernement et le président de la
république nous connaissons nous aussi
en france tous nous connaissons les
réformes à mener que nous voulons
imposer aux autres réformes fiscales
flexibilité du marché du travail réforme
de la retraite à points réforme réforme
réforme des statuts de la fonction
publique et allègement des normes si peu
a été réalisée chez nous monsieur le
ministre si dans les négociations notre
voie n'a pas tant compté que l'on
voudrait nous le faire croire
et bien c'est tout simplement parce que
nos partenaires ne sont pas dupes
notre crédibilité malheureusement
s'amenuise au fur et à mesure que nous
confondons depuis des années il faut
bien le dire réforme et affichage alors
nous devons également apprendre et tirer
des leçons de ce lourd épisode une
monnaie orpheline à la fois d'état est
orpheline de dimension politique
n'existe pas l'euro on ne pas
s'effondrer doit être enfin soutenu par
un véritable gouvernement économique
nous ne pouvons plus continuer avec une
telle architecture qui en guise d'
architecture ressemble plus à un
règlement de copropriété bien usé il
faut se rendre compte que l'eurogroupe
n'est qu'une structure virtuelle
rien dans les traités n'est prévu pour
donner des orientations politiques à
notre monnaie avoir un ministre à temps
partiel pour gérer leur groupe ce n'est
plus possible
nous ne pouvons plus donné dans la
politique de l'expédient de l'accord de
dernière minute et du rafistolage
l'europe ne doit pas fonctionner ainsi
l'europe ne peut plus avancer ainsi il
faut donner du corps et un visage à
l'euro monsieur le ministre des affaires
étrangères nous sommes en parfaite
harmonie avec vos propos tenus il ya
quelques minutes nous devons sur ce
point nous devons donner à l'europe une
voie pour répondre à celle des peuples
nous devons lui donner des bras pour
agir on ne peut pas non plus laisser les
peuples européens croire qu'une
intervention de la troïka serait une
ingérence antidémocratique
il faut passer à un autre système
nous avons donc besoin d'une nouvelle
gouvernance de la zone euro pour assurer
en effet la convergence de nos
politiques publiques
nous avons besoin d'un sursaut
démocratique et fédérale en permettant
la désignation d'un responsable européen
d'un ministre des finances si l'on veut
qui détiendra l'autorité suffisante pour
imposer le respect de la règle commune
hélas la france a un rôle à jouer
nous ne pouvons pas laisser nous
français la zone euro sans clé de voûte
essais j'ai entendu en effet les
propositions faites hier par le
président de la république il semble
enfin nous rejoindre sur la nécessité de
faire un pas en avant dans la marche
vers le fédéralisme budgétaire européen
enfin bravo bravo mais monsieur le
ministre nous avons besoin de garanties
que vous rejoindrez le geste à la parole
très rapidement évidemment tout le monde
a bien compris
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
que le débat est loin très loin d'être
terminée parce que nous nous croyons en
europe parce que nous voulons construire
l'europe de demain une europe solidaire
une europe exigeante nous voterons en
faveur de la validation de cet accord je
vous remercie
merci monsieur le président la parole
est maintenant président jean bizet pour
le groupe l'est républicain
et pour 17 minutes maximum vous avez la
parole monsieur le président monsieur le
président messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues au terme d'une nouvelle
nuit de négociations dont seule l'europe
elle se crée l'accord trouvé par les
chefs d'état et de gouvernement de la
zone euro éloigne pour un temps au moins
peut-être le spect d'une sortie
chaotique de la grèce de la monnaie
unique
cependant cet accord à me semble-t-il
comme un air de déjà vu
voilà en effet plus de cinq ans que
périodiquement l'europe et la grèce
semble condamnée à rejouer encore et
toujours la même scène depuis 2010 d'un
plan d'un montant total de 240 milliards
d'euros ont été mis en oeuvre pour aider
les grecs à surmonter les difficultés
auxquelles il devait faire face dans la
tourmente économique et financière que
connaissait alors notre continent
la solide et européennes a joué à plein
elle était indispensable
d'autres pays que la grèce en ont
d'ailleurs également profiter ils sont
désormais en voie de rétablissement car
eux ont fait les réformes qui s'imposent
et pourtant aujourd'hui la dette grecque
atteint des records à 180% du pib' elle
serait au demeurant encore plus élevé si
en 2012
les états européens n'avaient pas
contrat les créanciers privés assumer
leur part de risque et haïfa c'est
l'équivalent de 107 milliards d'euros
qu'il détenait en obligations et bons du
trésor la bce a également contribué à
l'expression de la solidarité européenne
cela fait maintenant cinq mois
cinq mois qu'elle porte à bout de bras
le système bancaire grec et donc
l'économie du pays
elle lui a ainsi fourni près de 90
milliards d'euros de liquidités
d'urgence alors que parallèlement les
déposants ont retiré depuis décembre
2014 plus de 40 milliards d'euros ce qui
est beau ce qui équivaut à près de 25%
du produit intérieur brut
la réouverture des banques dont la date
exacte reste à ce jour incertaine
à la suite des récentes déclarations du
premier ministre grec
devra toutefois est accompagné d'une
recapitalisation conséquente pouvant
aller selon l'eurogroupe jusqu'à 25
milliards d'euros dans la conception de
chaque plan daide la responsabilité grec
devait répondre à cette solidarité
européenne et se manifester par des
réformes structurelles ambitieuses
destinées à assainir les finances
publiques du pays et à remettre les
rails sur les rails une économie qui
s'est désormais admis ne disposait
absolument pas de des pré requis
fondamentaux pour prétendre faire partie
de la zone euro or aujourd'hui quelle
est la nature de l'accord qui nous est
soumis tout d'abord un engagement pour
un nouveau plain dead le troisième je le
rappelle dont les contours précis sont
encore inconnues mais qui sera doté
d'une enveloppe d'environ 85 milliards
sur trois ans avec une participation
européenne qui se réévalue à ce stade à
50 milliards si l'on se base sur la
quote-part de notre pays au sein du ms
mécanisme européen de stabilité
cette nouvelle étape représenterait pour
la france plus de 10 milliards d'euros
qui s'ajouteront donc aux 42 milliards
précédent sur les plans antérieurs soit
une contribution directe global de 55
milliards d'euros un prêt relais devra
par ailleurs être consentis dans les
jours qui viennent pour que la grèce
puisse régulariser sa situation de
défaut vis-à-vis du fmi et faire face à
ses échéances de remboursement à très
court terme estimé par l'eurogroupe à 12
milliards d'euros d'ici la fin du mois
d'août le fonds pour les investir les
privatisations nouvellement créé c'est
une nouveauté devra quant à lui
impérativement atteindre son objectif de
50 milliards d'euros pour sécuriser les
nouveaux prêts consentis précisément par
les européens enfin si des aménagements
de la dette grecque sont aujourd'hui
envisagée ils ne pourront intervenir
qu'après la mise en oeuvre par le
gouvernement grec de ses engagements
conformément j insiste bien gelée d'il
ya huit jours conformément aux principes
l'accord conclu en novembre 2012 et
confirmé par cet accord du 13 juillet ne
pourront en aucun cas porter sur une
décote sur 1 ou sur un effacement de la
dette nominale de la grèce une fois ce
programme mis en oeuvre ce seront donc
au total plus de 500 milliards d'euros
qui auront été mobilisé d'une manière ou
d'une autre en faveur de la grèce depuis
2010 dans ces conditions et là je
rejoins avec force notre collègue scotto
parler de coup d'état financier ou de
dictature de la finance comme le font
certains et grotesque nous avons déjà
donné 500 milliards d'euros à la grèce
ne tombons pas dans le piège de monsieur
qui brasse l'europe a été plus que
solidaires et c'est la grèce qui elle ne
s'est pas réformé n'inversons pas les
responsabilités
j'observe à ce titre que si le
gouvernement s'y pressent n'a finalement
pas obtenu le chèque en blanc qu'il
escomptait c'est en grande partie grâce
à la fermeté qu'ont su démontrer nombre
de pays européens emmenés notamment par
la chancelière allemande
je ne peux que m'en réjouir je m'en
réjouis car n'oublions pas que ce pays
est le premier financeur du mécanisme
européen de stabilité
quoi qu'on en dise quoi qu'on en dise
est bel et bien cette position qui se
reflète dans le résultat final des
négociations
je regrette je le dis très clairement
que la france ait prêté une oreille que
je qualifierais de sélective plus
attentive aux voies plus attentive aux
voix de l'extrême gauche qu'à celle des
réformateurs et qui a trop longtemps
laissé entendre à monsieur de sipera ce
qu'il bourré qu'il pourrait bénéficier
d'une nouvelle fois de la solidarité
européenne sans accepter la
responsabilité qui va avec
c'est un affront fait aux contribuables
français
la france et l'europe ne peuvent pas
continuer à payer sans contrepartie sans
exigence nous ne pouvons donc que saluer
le travail de la chancelière
il est vrai il est vrai je le dis très
clairement
il est vrai il est vrai que leur taux
d'auxi 2 il est vrai que il est vrai que
l'europe de l'orthodoxie fidèles de
l'orthodoxie budgétaire ne fait pas
rêver
c'est vrai mais là au moins un mérite
c'est celle d'assurer les fans mois des
pays en difficulté ne l'oublions pas et
c'est un message c'est un message que je
me permettrai d'adressé personnellement
et beaucoup d'autres aussi à monsieur
mélenchon mais quel paradoxe de voir
aujourd'hui la france approuvé pour la
grèce
quel paradoxe de voir aujourd'hui la
france approuvé pour la grèce ce qu'il
refuse précisément à notre pays il
serait bon que le prêt à la république
s'inspire aujourd'hui des réformes qu'il
a finalement soutenu dans cet accord et
dont il ne me paraît pas vouloir pour
notre pays
les réformes
les réformes structurelles engagées ces
dernières années avaient été remis à la
grèce d'enregistrer des résultats
économiques positifs à partir de 2014 et
d'entrevoir enfin une sortie de crise
elle dégage ainsi un premier excédent
budgétaire primaire la croissance
commencer à repartir après six années de
réception elle avait même fait un
premier retour encourageant sur les
marchés financiers mais l'incertitude
politique qui règne depuis plusieurs
mois et le coup d'arrêt donné aux
réformes par monsieur cipra sont réduits
à néant ces avancées les exigences de
l'accord du 13 juillet doivent donc
permettre à la grèce de réenclencher la
dynamique vertueuse sur lesquels elle
s'était engagée il ya encore moins d'un
an mais la grèce devra avant tout régler
ce qui fait encore aujourd'hui ça
faiblesses structurelles fondamentales
chacun ne connaît désormais que trop
bien ces défaillances un état et une
administration inefficace et miné par la
corruption et le clientélisme un système
social totalement inadapté un système
fiscal d'un autre temps ou encore une
culture
et oui on a découvert une culture de la
fraude et de l'évasion fiscale mortifère
pour ne pas craindre d'avoir à discuter
demain d'un éventuel quatrième plan
daide la confiance dans la volonté dans
la capacité du gouvernement grec à
transformer réellement son pays pour le
mettre au niveau des standards européens
est donc fondamental or cette confiance
est aujourd'hui considérablement et
rodez et rodez pour un certain nombre
d'européens
elle est même entièrement brisées cette
défiance qui s'est installée et bien
évidemment le fruit des errements et des
compromissions des divers gouvernements
grecs qui se sont succédé depuis
plusieurs décennies
c'est vrai les uns et les autres c'est
vrai mais elle est surtout le résultat
de lassitude de monsieur type racette
ses amis depuis six mois
depuis leur arrivée au pouvoir
quand ils ont ils entrepris pour
adresser véritablement ce pays aucune
action d'envergure n'a été menée depuis
l'élection du 25 janvier alors même que
monsieur series avait reçu un mandat
fort pour s'attaquer fermement à la
corruption aux privilèges fiscaux
injustifiée qui font d'ailleurs pesé sur
une base bien trop étroite
le poids des ajustements structurelles
indispensables et qui font le malheur de
la grèce ou de plus également de ses
habitants au lieu de cela le
gouvernement de chypre as a préféré se
concentrer uniquement sur la question de
la dette et sur le versement d'une
dernière tranche dead dont il disait
pourtant durant sa campagne électorale
ne pas vouloir
ce faisant il s'est enferré dans une
logique d'affrontement stérile et
démagogique avec ses partenaires
européens
en cinq mois de négociations jamais ne
s'est engagé dans une discussion
sérieuse et concrète
pas une fois il n'a formulé la moindre
proposition crédible se contentant
d'instrumentaliser la menace d'un échec
des négociations est d'une sortie de la
grèce de la zone euro
pire il a régulièrement fait usage de la
provocation voire de l'insulté comme
lorsque le ministre des finances se
permettait de traiter ouvertement ses
interlocuteurs je cite les mots de
terroristes ou de criminels
enfin la décision soudaine et
unilatérale de monsieur six phrases de
se retirer des discussions pourtant
devenir ainsi constructive pour
convoquer un référendum et faire
campagne pour le non a fini de
convaincre la plupart de ses partenaires
qu'ils ne pouvaient pas voir en lui un
interlocuteur fiable
j'ajoute que malgré l'engagement pris
les par les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement de négocier un troisième
plan daide conséquent les mesures que
devra mettre en oeuvre le gouvernement
grec sont semblables voire plus
exigeantes encore que celle que sa
majorité avaient appelé à rejeter dans
le cadre du référendum du 5 juillet
alexis trip race est donc aujourd'hui
mis face à ses contradictions et le
mythe s'effondre pour ceux qui au matin
du 26 janvier
j'entends encore certains voyaient en
lui l'alpha et l'oméga d'une
réorientation de l'europe
dans ces conditions on peut légitimement
s'interroger sur les marges de
manoeuvres politiques dont son
gouvernement pourra bénéficier dans les
semaines et les mois à venir d'autant
plus que le premier ministre lui même a
affirmé hier ne pas croire au plan de
réforme qu'il soit qu'il doit désormais
mettre en oeuvre même si plusieurs
parties semble aujourd'hui prêt à
soutenir l'agenda de réformes proposées
comme l'a d'ailleurs démontré le vote de
la vouli vendredi dernier les premières
voix discordantes ne sont par ailleurs
déjà fait entendre au sein de la
plateforme majoritaire or ce dont la
grèce a aujourd'hui besoin par dessus
tout c'est bien de stabilité après six
mois d'incertitude d'inconstance et
d'inaction
seule la stabilité permettra à la grèce
de s'engager dès maintenant sur des
actes forts le vote prévu aujourd'hui
sur un certain nombre de réformes clés
est un premier test de la capacité des
grecs à emprunter cette voie
mais ne nous y trompons pas les actions
nécessaires à la remise en route pérenne
du pays prendront du temps
c'est donc seulement dans la durée que
nous pourrons véritablement mesurer la
volonté politique des grecs de se doter
d'un état et d'une économie moderne
capable de se passer de la surveillance
et de la sciss force de ses partenaires
européens lundi l'europe a donné dans la
douleur il est vrai une ultime chance à
la grèce de démontrer qu'elle était
capable de demeurer membre de la monnaie
unique
néanmoins à cette crise laissera n'ont
pas douté des marques profondes et
durables dans les relations entre les
grecs et le reste des européens mais
aussi entre les européens eux mêmes et
en particulier je suis désolé monsieur
nuit
sera de vous contredire c'est mon
analyse le permettait entre la france et
l'allemagne dont les divergences
d'analysé dans la phase finale des
négociations ont malgré tout éclaté au
grand jour
l'europe a certes évité et il fallait le
faire le saut dans l'inconnu qu'aurait
constitué une sortie incontrôlée de la
grèce de la grèce de la zone euro mais
elle ressort toutefois politiquement
affaiblie et divisée de cette
interminable psychodrame fort
heureusement elle n'a pas sans elle n'a
pas cédé au chantage de monsieur trip
race et c'est au delà de la et c'est au
delà de la grèce un avertissement à tous
les populistes que nous avons ici elle a
malheureusement dans certains pays
espérons que cette énième crise aura au
moins servi à faire prendre conscience
aux grecs de l'ampleur des défis qui se
posent à eux mais aussi et surtout du
fait que l'europe ne pourra en aucun cas
se permettre de revivre ce genre
d'épisode une discussion sur un cas
tient un quatrième plan d' aide à la
grèce éventuels ou sur un effacement de
sa dette signifierait alors cette fois
ci les perspectives d'un grec cite enfin
cette séquence a démontré une fois de
plus à quel point la zone europe a tissé
de ses déficiences structurelles
la convergence de nos modèles
économiques en particulier dans le
domaine fiscal et social
la france est en retard dans ces
domaines ainsi qu'un réel pilotage
politique de la zone euro ne peuvent
plus aujourd'hui rester des débats
théoriques ou des voeux pieux
ils sont tout simplement une urgence
politique économique pour la zone euro
lorsque le traitait de marcy le
maastricht mettant en place l'union
économique et monétaire fut signé en
le tandem mitterrand delors était
convaincu que l'europe amènerait à une
convergence naturelle des économies
européennes et que l'union économique
suivrait l'union monétaire dans les
trois ans nous sommes aujourd'hui loin
de cette prédiction et les retards qu'en
la matière relève je dois l'avouer d'une
faute collective d'une faute collective
que nous devons assumer
mais si la france mais si la france a de
l'audace il paraît qu'elle en a
désormais si la france a de l'audace
elle doit désormais prendre l'initiative
est faire des propositions concrètes et
ambitieuses à ses partenaires dans sa
grande majorité le groupe des
républicains validera cette proposition
d'accord négocié par le d les dix neuf
états de la zone euro c'est-à-dire la
signature de la france
car il faut savoir respecter la parole
de son pays
j'invite je le sais un certain nombre de
nos collègues emporté par le
comportement de monsieur sip race à
dépasser leurs sentiments qui peut la
douleur pour encore une fois réfère
respecter la parole de la france en
votant cet accord européen mais je
dirais que ce vote positif ne peut
s'appréhender sans un contrôle régulier
et précis du respect de la totalité de
l'accord européen en d'autres termes en
d'autres termes il ne peut y avoir deux
versements dead échelonnées dans le
temps sans respect strict de ses
engagements par la grèce et le
gouvernement français monsieur le
ministre monsieur le ministre doit 110
haies doit s'engager sur cette exigence
de contrôler le sénat quant à lui au
travers de cette commission des finances
et la commission des affaires
européennes
lui n'y manquera pas je vous remercie
merci monsieur le président la parole
est au président didier guillaume pour
le groupe socialiste et républicain
lavez la parole monsieur merci monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues
monsieur le ministre étant étrangère je
suis au regret une fois de plus de
mettre à mal votre modestie mais je
voudrais vraiment avant d'évoquer la
grèce salué le travail de la france du
chef de l'état du gouvernement et de
vous-même pour l'accord historique qui a
été obtenu avec avec l'iran et je pense
qu'il faut le saluer à sa juste valeur
c'est la fin c'est la fin de la
prolifération
c'est le début de nouveaux accords et
pour cela monsieur le ministre
toutes les félicitations du groupe
socialiste et républicain
mais pour en revenir à la pour en
revenir au dossier sur la grèce que de
chemin parcouru depuis la semaine
dernière et relisons les les
interventions les discours
je me suis amusé tout à l'heure à re
lire le compte-rendu analytique ce que
disaient les uns et les autres que
n'avons nous pas entendu celles et ceux
qui souhaitaient le grec cite que là que
la grèce sorte de la zone euro parce
qu'elles n'avaient rien à y faire
parce qu'elle était dépensière peut-être
tout simplement parce qu'elle ne parlait
pas le même langage que le reste des
états européens et qu'elle réussit
aujourd'hui pour la grèce qui
aujourd'hui dans l'euro dans l'europe et
dans le peuple va essayer de s'en sortir
avec son gouvernement
quelle réussite pour l'europe oui pour
l'europe parce que lorsqu'on travaille
sur un espace politique économique
européen
on l'est on ne laisse pas de côté au
bord du chemin
ceux qui ont du mal à suivre bien au
contraire on essaie de les faire rentrer
dans le peloton pour que tout le monde
aille en haut du col et puisse gagner
quelle réussite pour la zone euro
qu'aurions nous dit après qu'aurions
nous dit après un départ de la grèce
qu'aurions nous dit après un départ de
la grèce que se serait-il passé
et puis quelle réussite pour le couple
franco allemand
n'en déplaise à certains ce couple a
bien fonctionné et je pense qu'il y a
des moments plutôt que de faire du
cynisme ou de l'ironie mal placé il vaut
mieux encourager le travail de la france
et de l'allemagne a contribué comme elle
l'a ils l'ont fait depuis des années la
construction européenne oui la semaine
dernière nous évoquions notre groupe
évoqué et d'autre le fait que la grèce
sortant de la zone euro ce serait un
échec pour l'europe et nous appelons à
ce que la grèce y reste afin que
l'europe puisse voir un avenir le
meilleur possible et surtout que la
grèce en immense difficulté puissent
enfin se réformer essayez de voir demain
une meilleure situation pour ce pays par
rapport à son histoire mais surtout pour
ses habitants et le point d'équilibré
qui a été trouvé lundi dernier par
l'ensemble des chefs d'état est un point
d'équilibré qui doit tous nous
rassembler et qui devrait tous nous
amener à voter oui à la proposition de
vote
soumise par le gouvernement c'est un
acte fort pour l'europe
je crois que nous pouvons le dire et au
moment justement où l'europe est
fragilisée où l'europe est secouée où
l'europe a subi des soubresauts terrible
avec ce qui pouvait se passer ce qui
aurait pu se passer
vis-à-vis de la grèce nous parce que
nous sommes optimistes parce que nous
faisons confiance aux chefs d'état et de
gouvernement qui signe les traités parce
que nous faisons confiance aux
dirigeants des pays de l'europe
nous pensons au contraire que cette
signature peut être un nouveau départ
pour la construction européenne est pur
pour l'europe oui nous pensons que cette
signature cet accord a changé le
mouvement de l'europe
rappelez-vous nous étions une dizaine de
jours avec une grande majorité des états
européens avec une grande majorité de la
droite européenne favorable à la sortie
de là
grèce la zone euro nous sommes
aujourd'hui avec la grèce dans la zone
euro et des mesures qui sont prises et
qui devront être prises le plus
fortement possible
je crois qu'il faut arrêter mes chers
collègues de stigmatiser mais ce type
race le premier ministre arrêter de se
faire plaisir de parler de chantage
j'ai entendu pas de chèque en blanc mais
c'est faux jamais monsieur six places à
demander un chèque en blanc
alors si c'est le cas j'accepterai que
compte rendu swami les mots de monsieur
tsipras ce qui demande un chèque en
blanc jamais c'est une interprétation
fallacieuse de l'histoire simplement le
référendum qui a été fait la semaine
dernière le ray et je vous mets au défi
de le sortir l'art et le référendum qui
a défait la semaine dernière c'était
tout simplement nous l'avons dit je
l'assumé ici pour redonner de la dignité
au peuple grec
bien sûr que la question s'était pas de
dire qu'elle est quelle quelle mesure
qu'elle telle mesure va être prises
voulons nous que la grèce demain est
encore un avenir
et je ne partage pas la vision politique
lors de l'élection de monsieur de sipera
ce mais je partage avec lui une chose la
volonté de dire que pour des raisons
politique géostratégique géopolitique
par rapport à l'histoire de ce pays
formidable
la grèce doit être dans la zone euro et
dans l'europe
c'est ça notre histoire et c'est ça
l'europe sur laquelle nous voulons
encore nous voulons encore travailler et
je crois qu'il faudrait arrêter le
mépris vis-à-vis de monsieur de sip
races et des grecs et de la grèce nous
n'en sommes pas là aujourd'hui
ce que nous devons bâtir cessé de faire
en sorte que la grèce s'en sortent et
que l'europe s'en sortent
alors oui l'europe et dans et notre
avenir
mais cette europe là nous savons qu'elle
ne fonctionne pas très bien
et le constat nous pouvons le faire sur
tous les bancs avec des propositions
totalement différente
le vote que demande le gouvernement
aujourd'hui et le vote pour approuver un
accord ça a été dit par tout le monde
tout à l'heure on peut aller chercher
des exégèses ici ou là c'est l'accord
qui a été signé validé par monsieur
tsipras ce et au moment où le parlement
grec va voter l'accord la demande du
premier ministre grec
nous nous poserions des questions de ne
pas le signer
je pense que l'enjeu de cet accord
l'enjeu de ce moment c'est que nous
sommes le premier parlement mais c'est
que le parlement de la france à
l'assemblée nationale comme au sénat
vote
et puis il y aura des revoyure et nous
verrons comment les choses avanceront
alors oui quelques raisons pour adopter
cet accord qui me semble évidente
d'abord je vais vous le dire très
tranquillement je pense que dans une
dans un moment politique comme celui ci
il faut refuser la récupération
politique
le ministre
le ministre l'a dit tout à l'heure
le ministre italien il ne s'agit pas de
faire de la récupération politique
mais je vous le dis très tranquillement
mes chers collègues je refuse de
dénigrement politiciens parce que quand
l'afld car l'europe est en grande
difficulté car l'europe a failli se
noyer
car la grèce a failli sortir la zone
euro quand la france joue son rôle
et quand le président de la république
joue son rôle alors oui quand on est
opposant le rôle de l'opposant c'est de
soutenir c'est de soutenir la france
c'est de soutenir la patrie et non pas
toujours de rigoler d'être cynique parce
que ce n'est pas comme cela que nous
bâtirons la confiance en europe de la
france et je veux le dire très
tranquillement très tranquillement on
peut comprendre les débats et la
polémique interne sous la politique
française
mais l'enjeu de l'europe par rapport à
ce que ce continent a connu pendant la
guerre ce qu'il a connue après dans la
reconstruction vaut bien plus bien plus
que du dénigrement politiciens cet
accord cet accord évite ce qui compte ce
qui compte ce n'est pas l'enthousiasmé
c'est la vérité de nos convictions
monsieur poniatowski cette cet accord
d'urgence a demandé des réformes a
demandé des réformes indispensables et
monsieur chip race a signé en faisant
des réformes des réformes et nous
l'avions demandé nous aussi la semaine
dernière il n'était pas possible
il n'était pas possible d'accepter un
accord
non ce n'est pas la méthode coué n'était
pas pesé d'accepter un accord sans les
réformes comptait demander je vous
invite chers collègues à lire le plan
l'accord qui signer et vous verrez que
les grecs vont avoir des moments
difficiles et ils le
et ils le feront et je crois que c'est
très important nous devons enfin nous
devons enfin profiter de cet accord pour
que un nouveau chapitre de l'europe
s'ouvre je crois que c'est ça qui est
important
il faut des perspectives nouvelles le
chef de l'état l'a dit encore hier il
faut un gouvernement économique européen
fort plus fort qu'il ne l'est
aujourd'hui et je crois aussi que le
maintien de la grèce dans la zone euro
et dans l'union européenne
c'est vraiment une victoire pour les
défenseurs pour tous les défenseurs de
l'europe
alors oui cette gouvernance économique
européenne doit être mise en place
et pour ce faire le couple
franco-allemand doit continuer à jouer
un rôle fort un rôle comme il le joue
depuis 70 ans
tantôt la france a eu besoin de
l'allemagne tantôt l'allemagne avait
besoin de la france
mais jamais ce couple ne fonctionne
aussi bien que lorsqu'il fonctionne
ensemble panka pas quand l'un écrase
l'autre et nous ne sommes pas pour nous
mettre les diktats de la chancelière
allemande
nous sommes simplement pour que ce
couple franco allemand puisse travailler
ensemble comme il l'a fait ces derniers
temps et je vous invite d'ailleurs mes
chers collègues à écouter à lire les
journaux à écouter la télévision
allemande pour voir que la vision que
vous avez la vision que vous avez de la
france vue de l'allemagne n'est pas du
tout celle là et si et ce soir 2 ap et
vous verrez ce que en allemagne on dit
de cet accord
est ce qu'en allemagne on dit de du
couple franco allemand
et puis enfin c'est aussi un accord qui
conforte la france et je crois que c'est
important que la position de la france
est plus tenir beau ce n'est pas ce
n'était pas une position dogmatique la
volonté du chef de l'état du
gouvernement de la france de la
république française c'était un de tout
faire pour que la grèce reste dans
l'euro et dans l'europe
deuxièmement que la grèce fasse des
réformes indispensables structurelles
qu'elle avait commencé à faire mes
cannes n'a jamais bien fait et enfin
troisièmement que l'on discute sur le
rééchelonnement de la dette sur comment
les relations pourraient se
ce se passer et soutenir cet accord si
soutenir l'europe
si toute manière la grèce c'est soutenir
la zone euro
et c'est aussi quelque part venir le
couple franco-allemand et soutenir la
république française aussi pour ces
raisons au moment où le parlement grec
ce soir a voté pour
au moment où je l'espère beaucoup de
parlements européens voteront pour la
france doit le parlement français se
doit de voter oui à la question qui est
posée par le gouvernement pour conforter
la position de la france dans l'europe
pour préparer l'avenir de l'europe est
tout simplement pour faire en sorte que
demain les grecs vivent un peu mieux
qu'ils ne vivent aujourd'hui voter pour
c'est aussi préparer la suite
mesdames et messieurs mes chers
collègues je nous engage tous à préparer
la suite de l'europe je vous remercie
merci monsieur le président la parole
est à monsieur andré gattolin pour le
groupe écologiste et pour six minutes
mais la parole je suis un collègue
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre des affaires étrangères
monsieur le ministre de l'économie mais
chers collègues
une semaine après nous voici donc à
nouveau réunis pour discuter du sort de
la grèce
mais cette fois ci il s'agit pour nous
de nous prononcer sur un accord trouvé à
l'arraché à la suite d'une longue et
pénible nuit de négociations à bruxelles
en début de semaine le moment de débat
que nous menons ici est particulièrement
solennel car plusieurs parlements
nationaux de l'union sont amenés à
s'exprimer
et le hasard veut que nous procédions en
france à ce sujet en quasi simultanéité
avec le parlement grec
il ne s'agit plus ici de questionner les
responsabilités respectives des uns et
des autres le temps est avenue est à
présent venu en âme et conscience
d'acter ou de rejeter l'accord trouvé
et disons le clairement c'est sur des
formes exacerbées de cynisme d'égoïsme
et d'humiliation que leur groupe a
procédé à cette négociation perdant
ainsi de vue la solidarité et la
cohésion qui aurait dû guider ses pas et
pourtant c'est bel et bien prêt d'un
précipice que l'europe vient de passer
et sans que sa conduite soit
particulièrement louable elle a
cependant su pour le moment ne pas
tomber dedans
elle ne s'est pas échoué dans l'abyme
car même si le peuple grec est
aujourd'hui soumis et zad terrible
contrainte
l'accord proposé à éviter un scénario
bien pire celui du grec cite même
provisoire soutenue un temps par
l'allemagne
comme j'ai eu l'occasion de le souligner
la semaine dernière cela aurait été une
totale aberration politique et
géopolitique géostratégique a précisé
notre ministre est surtout économique
par son coût bien plus élevé que le
maintien de la grèce dans la zone euro
nous avons échappé au pire mais au prix
d'un accord extrêmement brutal il faut
le dire pour la grèce parmi les réformes
demandé et obtenu par les créanciers de
la grèce certaines me semble dangereuse
et suscite de très légitimes
interrogations
tout d'abord il est demandé au
gouvernement de s'y pressent de compte
culte est en permanence et au préalable
la troïka sur tout nouveau projet de loi
qu'il serait amené à proposer
c'est une liste sous tutelle
systématique qui est inacceptable et qui
constitue c'est un fédéraliste européen
qui le dit une véritable atteinte à sa
souveraineté
en plus de cela on organise la mise sous
tutelle financière de 50 milliards de
ses biens dont la gestion reviendra un
fonds basé en grèce sur ce point je
tiens à saluer l'action d'alexis tsipras
ce qui a réussi bien heureusement
empêcher que le diffon de choix basé au
luxembourg
il ne manquerait plus que cela cela
reste hélas une bien maigre victoire car
ce fonds de privatisation n'est en
réalité rien de plus qu'une version
réactualisée de la société fiduciaire la
traîne en allemand qui fut chargé de la
privatisation d'entreprises en rda pur
moment de la réunification allemande
et c'est loin d'être une bonne nouvelle
personne d'autre que monsieur fiable
l'actuel ministre des finances
allemandes ne sait mieux à quel point
l'action de cette société fiduciaire fut
dur effroyable pour les allemands de
l'est
à cette époque il était en effet
ministre de l'intérieur du gouvernement
colle à la fin de sa période d'action
seuls 1,5 million d'allemands de l'est
avaient réussi à trouver un travail et
les caisses de l'état s'était retrouvé
avec 120 milliards d'euros de dette
alors qu'on s'attendait à obtenir 300
milliards de recettes
alors comment être optimiste quant à
cette mise sous tutelle financière
d'autres mesures risquent aussi de
pousser la grèce vers une asphyxie
économique et social comme par exemple
la réforme des retraites et la hausse
notable de la tva prévoir de telles
mesures pourquoi pas mais sans instaurer
en parallèle à l'instar de ce qui existe
en france ou en allemagne
un revenu minimum de solidarité nous
paraissent socialement insoutenable
alors l'accord très discutable adopté
lundi comporte quand même quelques
avancées pertinente
je pense ainsi à l'indépendance de
l'office grec de statistiques dans la
mise en place de réformes en faveur d'un
système fiscal enfin viable à la volonté
de mettre fin au clientélisme au sein de
l'administration grecque
et à l'affectation de 12,5 milliards
d'euros du fonds de privatisation en
faveur de l'investissement
alors on nous demande aujourd'hui nous
parlementaires français de nous
prononcer sur cet accord et c'est l'art
choix assez cornélien qui nous est posée
si nous ne nous nous trouvons
aujourd'hui dans une telle situation
c'est d'abord parce que nous n'avons pas
su doter l'europe des instances
composant un véritable fédéralisme
européen et par cette erreur nous
l'avons poussé sur une trajectoire dié
vaillante ayant abouti à une forme de
fédéralisme financier
lité par des instances financières pas
plus politique que démocratique une
europe dans laquelle les figures de
l'heureuse ils ont pour nom cohésion et
solidarité n'est pas non plus les robes
que nous souhaitons érigé pour conclure
sur le vote a donné sur cet accord un
nom qui sur le fond pour est justifiable
reviendrait en fait à ignorer l'appel à
l'aide du gouvernement grec et
reviendrait surtout à renier tous les
efforts qu'il a mise en place et un tel
nom et qu'on veut et qui voudraient
surtout un accord tacite pour une sortie
de la grèce de la zone euro
c'est pourquoi une très large majorité
au sein du groupe écologiste estime que
notre responsabilité historique
aujourd'hui et d'approuver cet accord
imparfait l'approuver faute de mieux
pour maintenir aujourd'hui la tête de la
grèce hors de l'eau et pour demain
engagé les actions nécessaires pour
aider les grecs à desserrer l'étau dans
lesquelles ils sont pris je vous
remercie
mais si mon cher collègue la parole est
maintenant notre collègue pierre laurent
pour le groupe communistes républicains
et citoyens et pour six minutes
lavez la parole
nous abordons le vote crucial
d'aujourd'hui conscient que le week-end
écoulé et le coup qu'il a porté à l'idée
européenne marqueront durablement les
esprits 3 sentiment anime notre groupe
la volonté de défendre l'intérêt du
peuple grec qui a eu le courage de se
lever par deux fois le 25 janvier lors
du référendum pour crier à la face de
l'europe sa souffrance et son exigence
de voir se lever le pilon qui l'écrasent
nous redisons ce soir vis au peuple grec
digne et libre et nous saluerons alexis
tsipras ce dont le courage et la
responsabilité politique sont
exemplaires
le second sentiment c'est la colère
contre la violence de nombre des
dirigeants de l'union européenne au
premier rang desquels angela merkel et
wolfgang schaüble
ils viennent de montrer quel intérêt ils
défendent qu'un peuple se lève contre
l'ordre libéral et l'oligarchie
financière et leur seule préoccupation
est de le soumettre et de le punir
depuis le premier jour ils n'ont jamais
rechercher un accord viable avec la
grèce est organisé dès le lendemain du
25 janvier son asphyxie financière et il
voulait la tête d'alexis de sipera ce le
référendum a douché leur tentative de
coup de force
ils se sont alors acharnés jusqu'à la
dernière minute a provoqué un grec 6-2
fait alexis tsipras ce porteur du mandat
de son peuple de rester dans la zone
euro et de faire respecter la
souveraineté de la grèce dans l'union
européenne s'y est refusée avec juste
raison
dès lors leur choix et l humiliation et
le chantage pour imposer le couteau sous
la gorge
un nouveau plan drastique à la grèce ses
dirigeants et leurs méthodes sont la
honte de l'europe et des millions
d'européens ne l'oublierons pas le
troisième sentiment est alors celui
d'une très grande inquiétude pour
l'avenir de l'europe
elle saigne dans les coeurs et dans les
têtes de millions d'européens ciel
continue ainsi tous ceux qui persistent
à soutenir de telles méthodes près d'une
très grave responsabilité devant
l'histoire
parce que des frustrations et des
humiliations générés
par une telle arrogance et par la seule
loi du plus fort naîtront des monstres
aux politiques qu'ils grandissent déjà
au coeur de l'europe
la première leçon à tirer l impérieuse
nécessité après ce qui s'est passé de la
refondation sociale politique et
démocratique de l'union européenne et
son image et son émancipation urgente
des logiques financières qui l'étouffent
l'accord qui nous est soumis et cartes à
première vue le grec site qui était et
qui reste l'objectif des dirigeants
allemands
alexis tsipras sa d'hier avec une grande
loyauté dans quelles conditions il a
assumé un accord contraint et forcé pour
éviter ce cauchemar je sais que devant
la brutalité de cet accord certains en
viennent à penser que le regret qu site
ne serait plus qu'un moindre mal
je ne le crois pas et les grecs non plus
parce qu'une sortie de la zone euro
ferait passer la grèce de la crise
humanitaire actuelle à l'hécatombe
regardez comment dans le dos de monsieur
choi bleu marine le pen et les siens
attendent le grec cite comme la victoire
enfin reporter pour sonner le glas de la
solidarité européenne
mais l'accord n'a pas levé ce risque en
choisissant d'imposer à la grèce une
mise sous tutelle insupportable et de
nouvelles de mesures d'austérité
draconiennes
joseph stiglitz a déclaré les efforts
demandés à athènes dépasse la sérénité
la sévérité il recèle un esprit de
vengeance
si les exigences des créanciers sont
respectés jusqu'au bout elle s'avère ont
une nouvelle fois injuste socialement et
contre productive économiquement
alexis que ce prince a redit sa volonté
de protéger les plus faibles et d'aller
chercher les nouvelles recettes fiscales
contre ceux qui s'enrichissent
il a redit la nécessité des
investissements productifs et
l'allègement du fardeau de la dette
mais tout est fait en réalité y compris
dans l'accord pour l'en empêcher
ainsi en va-t-il du programme démentiel
de privatisation qui figurent dans cet
accord et les rapaces sont déjà à
l'oeuvre
vinci est parait-il déjà sur place pour
racheter les aéroports plusieurs
engagements financiers sont envisagées
dans l'accord à la donne
de la grèce un programme de
refinancement un rééchelonnement partiel
de la dette et un plan d'investissement
sans ses engagements il n'y aura pas de
relance
or sous la pression de l'allemagne tous
ces engagements sont rendus hypothétique
et seront soumis au chantage permanent
des créanciers c'est le supplice de
tantale qui continue quant à la france
si le président de la république a joué
tardivement un rôle positif pour éviter
l'ogre excite elle a accepté dans la
nuit dans la dernière nuit le prix et
que le prix exorbitant afic à payer soit
fixé par angela merkel qui a dicté
finalement ces conditions la france
n'est donc pas qui tu es nous ne pouvons
encore moins après ça comme si de rien
était célébré le couple indestructible
franco allemand il faut poursuivre le
débat et la bataille
certains voudraient refermer la parade
la parenthèse grecque
notre intérêt commun est au contraire de
pousser au changement dans toute
l'europe pour la libérer de ses forces
libérales la france doit agir
immédiatement pour obtenir le déblocage
immédiat ce qui n'est toujours pas qui
alors qu'il ait des liquidités de la bce
sans les soumettre à de nouvelles
conditions pour mobiliser le plus vite
possible les 35 milliards
d'investissements prévus en engageant
sans tarder la contribution de la france
et en proposant à d'autres pays de se
joindre à la création d'un fonds de
développement pour la grèce adossé à la
bce
et enfin elle doit travailler à
concrétiser leur échelonnement de la
dette
notre au vote est aujourd'hui un acte de
lutte et de solidarité aux côtés du
peuple aux grecs d'alexis de sip race et
de syriza
nous sommes solidaires de leur choix et
à sion lors difficile et courageux
combat
nous sommes à leurs côtés pour dire non
à l'expulsion de la grèce mais nous
disons d'un même mouvement au nom de la
france et du rôle qu'elle doit jouer que
l'accord scandaleux imposé à bruxelles
n'est pas digne de l'europe et qu'aucun
maintien dans l'euro ne peut le
légitimer voilà pourquoi le groupe crc
votre a majoritairement contre cet
accord
la parole est au président jacques
mézard pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique social et européen
tu me président
la parole monsieur le président merci
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues
la question qui est soumise à notre
haute assemblée consiste à donner ou non
un quitus à la signature d'un accord
dont on peut dire qu'il est une étape
nécessaire à défaut d'être historique
terme dans l'histoire elle-même démontre
qu'il convient d'user avec précaution
étape nécessaire pour éviter un saut
dans l'inconnu
une sortie de la grèce de l'euro
procédure inédite non prévus
institutionnellement et dont l'analyse
des conséquences tant économiques que
politiques ne sauraient être réellement
apprécié que postérieurement
d'ailleurs ceux qui s'opposent à cet
accord et leurs opinions et respectables
ont des difficultés à exprimer et à
exposer une solution concrète réaliste
permettant de solutionner le problème
à défaut d'être historique
cet accord a une nouvelle fois démontré
que le couple franco allemand est à la
fois le socle de la construction
européenne et que tout ce qui contribue
à le fragiliser et dangereux pour
l'europe
le rôle du président de la république a
été important est salué comme tel dans
la réalisation de cet accord monsieur le
président guillaume voyez il m'arrive de
le dire et nous nous en réjouissons
on peut considérer d'ailleurs que loin
d'un conflit franco allemand c'est
plutôt une complémentarité qui est à
retenir une profonde expérience de l'art
de la synthèse entre des propositions
diamétralement opposées a sans nul doute
facilité l'issue de la négociation
passé le ouf de soulagement poussé par
les bourses européennes le réveil est
néanmoins difficile et la
surmédiatisation de la crise en grande
partie propagée par le premier ministre
grec lui même n'a rien
rangez les premières réactions de ce
dernier sitôt rentré à athènes illustre
que cet accord n'est qu'une étape et que
la crise grecque n'est pas terminée la
maladie n'a pas tué le patient le
médicament ne l'a pas encore sauvé
monsieur tsipras ce demande à son
parlement de voter un accord auquel ils
ne croient pas autrement dit une
signature sous la contrainte
mais il n'est pas françois 1er face à
charles quint des années ont été perdus
temps par la grèce qu par l'europe et
les pays qui respectent leurs
engagements n'accepteront pas demain une
nouvelle fois de contribuer ceci étant
on ne saurait rester sourds aux
interpellations du fmi qui conditionne
sa participation au nouveau plan un
allègement voir un effacement d'une
partie de la dette grecque
il faudra y parvenir monsieur le
ministre des affaires étrangères l'a
justement relevé
c'est inéluctable et l'allemagne ne
pourra et ne devrait et ne devra pas
oublier mes chers collègues qu après
chaque guerre mondiale elle a bénéficié
de la sollicitude forcé ou amicales de
ses créanciers
comment d'ailleurs éluder le fait que le
fmi constate la détérioration
spectaculaire de la solvabilité de la
dette grecque qui approchera les 200% de
son pib dans les deux ans cela alors que
l'accord prévoit simplement des mesures
additionnelles d'allègement de la dette
si athènes tient ses engagements
or le fmi devait participer et devrait
participer au nouveau plan de
financement de secours à la grèce
de plus de 80 milliards d'euros est
normalement ne peut prêter de l'argent à
un pays qui lui en doit tout concourt à
mettre en évidence que la dette grecque
va encore généré bien des soubresauts
politiques et économiques et des drames
humains
conséquence mes chers collègues de tant
de promesses démagogiques des
gouvernements que de l'impéritie des
banques qui ont facilité ses promesses
dans un objectif spéculatifs en passant
ensuite lardoise leurs errements non
sanctionnées aux états et aux citoyens
européens
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
au moment où nous allons émettre un vote
majoritairement positif à cet accord
qu'au moins cette crise est une vertu
que des leçons soient tirées sur les
institutions européennes avec un
parlement à 28/100 aucun poids sur un
débat concernant les 19 de l'euro sur la
gouvernance économique qui ne se gère
pas en un jour mais ou des spas peuvent
et doivent être faits aussi sur le
système bancaire
il est plus facile mes chers collègues
de gagner un référendum contre
l'austérité
quand appelé ses concitoyens à la
rigueur mais cela n'est aucunement une
spécialité grecque
nous pouvons y réfléchir sérieusement et
je laisse faire sereinement en tout cas
dans l'instant et dans l'attentes notre
groupe à l'exception de notre excellent
collègue pierre yves collombat votera
pour l'accord qui est présenté à nos
suffrages
merci merci c'est la fin de cette
édition spéciale merci à vous de l'avoir
suivi très bonne suite à des programmes
sur les chaînes parlementaires